have you been playing Grand Theft Auto 5
on your playstation 4 or xbox one lately
and notice that the game doesn't seem to
look quite as good as you remember well
don't rush off to the optician or brain
doctor just yet it seems that the recent
1.08 patch has actually caused a slip in
the game's looks I'm cam and this is a
game spot news update in the video on
screen now made by youtube user el
análisis de bits which translates
roughly as the analyzer of bits we can
see some of the graphical issues
painstakingly highlighted writing in
graphics effects such as parallax
occlusion and anisotropic filtering
along with texture pop-in and even the
damage modeling on cars following
collisions all seem to be negatively
impacted the good news is that Rockstar
is aware of the problem and doing
something about it in a statement added
to a support site on Thursday the
developer commented that we are aware of
some graphical issues on the Xbox one
and PlayStation 4 versions of GTA 5
after the most recent title updates and
we are investigating a fix now and in
fact since making that statement a 1.09
update has already been made available
across all platforms which according to
mr or ms bit analyzer has fixed the
poppin and collision issues but not the
rest for the full details of the changes
and fixes in the 1.09 patch head on over
to the Rockstar support site at the link
on screen now also good news for
previous generation console gamers as
none of these issues appear to be
affecting the xbox 360 or Playstation 3
editions of the game so have you been
playing Grand Theft Auto 5 on your
current gen system and not just some
graphical issues let me know in the
comments down below and to keep updated
on this story coming back to gain spot
or you can check out the Rockstar
support site
you